oh [ __ ] is the church that was a
tremendous bonnet greetings from podcast
Ville
it's February 6 2020 get your [ __ ]
together the Church of what's happening
now is brought to you by the zip
recruiter listen it's 2020 you want the
best [ __ ] people around you at all
times
hiring is challenging but there's one
place you can go hiring is simple fast
and smart you ready grab a pen
zip recruiter zipper coolers with
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates the understand ik zip recruit
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you and it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get the
qualified candidates faster with results
like that no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
the first day see why zip recruit is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at the
exclusive web app just just just go to
zip recruiter Tom slash Church that zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire the
church is also brought to you by on it
oh [ __ ] when it comes to supplements
silence the best why do I know because I
pay or why I smoke eighty four joints a
day I'm 57 I can't man what I ate for
breakfast buns look tip-top Magoo you
know I'm saying it keeps your mind sharp
alpha brain the trademark the [ __ ]
battleship of on it that's what I live
on and now since [ __ ] you got Chinese
people walking around with mass I got a
double up on the [ __ ] shrimp eat a
communion I'm saying I go to Koreatown I
got 88 of those and put on like a
[ __ ] hazmat suit now just to go get a
spare rib can you believe it so do me a
favor if you don't want the [ __ ]
carnivore
coronavirus how the [ __ ] it is go over
get yourself some shroom tech immune
right now right now immediately and then
get shrimp tech what's the other one
sport sport just the case you see a
Japanese guy and he breathes on you you
can start running some miles
excuse okay I'll try get to the bottom
is everybody gets accused alright that's
it
gonna calm right now by the way I that's
not responsible for my head and racial
and motivational views I'm talking to
you on my own
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] anyway go to
alikom right now impress in church boom
and get 10% off your first thought
delivered to the crib today we welcome
to the church to beautiful and one of
the best [ __ ] getting Twitter pages in
the business just to my Peluso [ __ ] I
love this [ __ ] because I can see you
while you're doing it
yeah like the whole [ __ ] the
positions in the mornings but in the
evenings a button the evening the bikini
running through and you do everything
very classy it's not everything that's
very funny and very silly I'm sure that
you don't get a lot of people saying
show me it did no I don't know I really
don't see no they see what are you doing
it's right so it's not like she's doing
it from a [ __ ] right you know yeah
take those sugar mamas I don't get any
dick pics I know they're it's not a it's
an interesting potty part I think I'd
rather I'm not gonna say what I'd rather
have because I know if I say it on this
it's gonna show up in my just a bunch of
taints it's my god I don't know I don't
have an impressive one but just by
itself your dick yeah it's like it's
just ok so I've never like I've sent a
couple times but like it's not something
that's all to me I would go to
you have casual dick energy no no it's
like more casual very carry are you
happy with it I could only use more but
I'm not depressed about it that's good
listen I was 27 si I'd submit picture to
my dick to your mother nobody wants to
see a picture my dad okay do dicks age
yes what's the first thing you noticed
like the change where you're like oh I'm
gonna color the color color changes
yes that's getting like this weird
awkward like Oh peg yeah like your balls
get darker it gets dark are you tanning
without pants I know number two months
ago without the people let there are so
that's you know those are [ __ ] put
then they get raped and they cry no I
lay in there with his legs wide oh
you're gay and crazy like there's gay
people live that certain lifestyle
sometimes they don't it's just crazy out
there yeah it is crazy did you put your
butthole and Sun I wanted to but I
didn't know what I wanted to put my
butthole in the Sun and get the vitamin
D right through the dirt star but I
didn't do it oh listen just go outside
and get vitamin D on your face and
that's enough yeah it is enough that's
it
yeah we have to put her but why do we
have to put her butt holes out you don't
when they did last study it was funny
one time I went to the doctor he said to
me off the golf he goes by the way your
physical you look good but you need more
vitamin D go out and get sunlight and I
got my car and I go what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
and weeks later months later I don't
[ __ ] know I saw an ad an article that
Californians
I liked the worst with vitamin D yeah we
don't get enough know what's because
when the house was scared most
Californians I scare the Sun because the
Sun cancer and whatever it's cool yeah
you need like 15 minutes a day she
sunlight no SPF I think I paid with the
taxes I [ __ ] pay if the Sun is out
you guarantee if I have a student
there's a part of the day where you just
have to return 18 course oh [ __ ] what
our emails or whatever but but the calls
are the main ones well I just go outside
I sit on my step that's nice
I got that 2:30 Sun and I'll just sit
there for 30 minutes just call it get
that fresh D let's get that fresh D the
disease for you there's a tree right
there which I'm getting some chlorophyll
I'm good yeah you get fresh air you know
you live in California you pay these
taxes you know let's talk about somebody
who said they bought a house and they're
moving down to the beach
[ __ ] can I go you know what do you think
and he goes you know it's a pricey
situation but he goes I'm a block away
from the [ __ ] Starbucks I could walk
and he goes if I'm gonna be away from my
family I'm gonna raise my kids on the
beach yeah I see that I want them to be
on the beach and sometimes we sit here
and wow you know we live in Glendale you
live in [ __ ] I'm on the west side
you're on the west are the ocean we
[ __ ] you can [ __ ] Syracuse yeah
bro coldest snowbelt and I'm from
[ __ ] Jersey : places one of us live
on the beach we all grew up on the image
of California one big beach did you do
lakes as a kid we did lakes and son
that's a closest we got to the ocean was
like a dirty ass lake you know I was
like I was a as you guys are on vacation
like they fight these five lakes in my
life you'd be surprised
I'd be surprised we have the one of the
dirtiest lakes in the country in
Syracuse on a dog lake it's just filled
with trash just filled with chemicals so
we don't really have a lake I used to do
swimming great competitions and [ __ ]
like that
you didn't competitive swimming like for
a while I did not even hold a red
Boulder resum I think that was like a
reservoir before I got locked up I got
into masters from in program before it
after yeah she talked me into the even
doing a biathlon where you ride a bike
and you swim a mile
one of those [ __ ] type of things
sounds like a nightmare no I wouldn't be
able to get through that just always
nervous in the water now yeah why so I
don't know why are you not a good
swimmer
no tremendous swimmer isn't it different
than like a lake versus a pool there's
so many you got a pool you got a lake
and you have a [ __ ] ocean okay in
rivers and then in pool you go as a
workout you go to your friends outfit
you got a drink I might jump in every
time I go on a heated pool I [ __ ] do
like a little exercise yeah you go all
the way deep on your bends you can throw
punches the 10 minutes water aquatics my
daughter so I I take him every year down
low to the hole for New Year's we get
down to a hotel and I got 18 pools yeah
I'm sitting there [ __ ] on the balcony
trying to smoke a number freezing to
death and I see a guy in the pool I see
steam coming out of it when I checked in
I asked the [ __ ] dude all the pools
called he goes yeah there's no heated
pools the next day I found that and I've
been to this hotel four [ __ ] times
and I finally found that thought the
pool right in front is heated as [ __ ]
nice warm cozy next to it that it's hot
interests remain this that's nice I'm
like [ __ ] it I went down there all four
days this time and I was going because I
my shoulders are done so I can't do I
can't do I come too fat to do the other
one have you ever thought about doing
stem cells so what I do is just pull the
stem cells is needles and blood yeah
that's right and you're not you're not
feeling that well I have been delray on
soon me and Dean flew one time and he
was telling me the procedure and Dean's
a good guy you know and Dean was telling
me that in when they was taking the
blood out to clean it and then before
they put it back on his neck he said he
passed out I'm not surprised
wow they were taking the blood out
I'm back brought him a smoothie but
[ __ ] blood kept going I would die
haematology smoothie I would die like a
fruit smoothie
wait when they take if you're a normal
fat [ __ ] but if you're a fat person like
me when they take more than a little
tube of blood out of you the first thing
you open your eyes is you want a can of
coke yeah the blood sugar the blood yeah
you try the coke I Morgan put you right
back to top everything whatever was out
yeah whatever was happening happen and
if you got a turkey sandwich with cheese
I used to give blood cuz a lot of times
you have to give blood with no food in
your stomach right that's torture
they're like no food no [ __ ] coffee
just mouthwash you gotta go down there
suck on that mouthwash the whole way
down and man this mint is good you pull
in there you got my boys you as soon as
that needle comes out all I'm thinking
about about food yeah I would bring
[ __ ] food with me ask you bribe
turkey sandwich yeah I would make my
wife make sure there's a nice day Swiss
on toast no we do a woman a can of coke
when you have surgery and they take it
to recovery they give you that trashy
Hasmukh gives you ass they give you
applesauce first whatever to blend into
your systems yeah you see digestion and
then after that they show up with a
turkey sandwich that you get a better
sandwich at prison yeah you really do
it's a 7-eleven sandwich oh no which I'm
not against it that's worse it's like a
7-eleven sandwich it had been dropped
like left out in the air for a couple of
days no no not that bad I mean the
hospital they give you a little [ __ ]
catch him a little mustard so you not
[ __ ] eat yeah so you're not like the
[ __ ] Swiss cheese
dry mouth too much [ __ ] turkey
sandwich
I know you're a big activist on stuff
yeah I really love that you breast
cancer [ __ ] vets I don't know who
else Alzheimer's
oh yeah it's my father passed away from
it 2018 and I just come you know smoke
weed and talk to my fans today actually
every Wednesday at five o'clock Pacific
I answer questions and just get stoned
and bring a little awareness to the
disease let people know the stigma and
the wrong things about it and try and
bring some light to it and bring some
joy or is it genetic
running your family from what I
understand the percentage of familial
Alzheimer's like the genetic side is a
very low percentage that it's mainly
from the things that I've read and what
I've learned that it's an inflammatory
disease of the brain which is caused by
a lot of extenuating circumstances
stress oxidative stress emotional stress
environmental stress your diet diets a
huge factor there's a really good book
by dr. Lisa Moscone called brain food
which is all about the correlation
between what you eat in the degradation
of your brain and the synapses and all
of the you know amyloids that build up
the plaques that cause Alzheimer's and
sort of how food can help prevent those
those sort of things happening you a
certain way because it it changed the
way I eat it changed everything yeah I
took a look at what I was eating and I
was scared I mean from a personal
standpoint it was my dad I didn't want
to lose him but also I share his blood
so it made me worried that I'm gonna be
predisposition to this so you know it
made me definitely switch when I eat but
I still enjoy [ __ ] I like I mean [ __ ]
grilled cheese sandwiches are so good
mac and cheese anything with cheese is
so [ __ ] good but that food is brutal
on your body
it's brutal I mean it's like between a
grape or a mac and cheese come on
you can go mac and cheese all day but it
definitely made me switch it up consider
that what do you avoid
I tried to avoid dairy I try to avoid
processed meat mainly meat in general
processed enriched flour any sort of
fake bread anything that doesn't perish
within a long time I try and eat as
healthy and clean as I can just had a
really interesting study yesterday more
than four slices of bacon a week of
[ __ ] show you how many slices of
bacon are you eaten only two slices at
the time cuz it's only three wait
watching points right that's good two
pieces you look younger and brighter
than I've remembered for a long time I
told it to you last time I saw you look
like you've gotten more fit are you
doing a lot yeah you look younger
no you look more rested weights yeah and
I focus that but I won't [ __ ] I will
not stop preaching that Rogan podcast
when he had the guy out of my sleep
sleep yo I had neither Stephen the
[ __ ] Steven Tyler podcaster Brogan I
could name me the top ten Rogen [ __ ]
podcast but the one that changed my life
completely
yeah wait why sleep is huge rolls to
sleep is huge guys and cleans itself out
I did I you know Lee thinks I goof on
them I swear to my [ __ ] daughter my
wife anything that sacred to me this
podcast I stopped taking naps at like
3:00 yeah when my father died so I
didn't happen that my mother told me she
knows as I'm raising you here you're
triggering was you can't sleep at a time
you away from so for a long time I
didn't take a nap I started dating a
stripper she would get home it - right
she'd get up at 8:00 we do our share we
go back
I never stabbed here on the stripper
schedule we take the we take the 2:30 to
find nap and she get up she needs
healthy no turkey burgers mushrooms and
stuff and the night stop drop her off at
the strip club
but she was the first person that
introduced me like she's not in apps and
apps there so I was out all day I was
raised what you've done and look at that
generation now that generation and then
now mixing the cocaine oh oh my god and
then throw in a disease I acquired in
like 98 why I didn't know that is the
number one growing disease and men that
will take you out it will take you out
and people [ __ ] don't have an idea
sleep apnea will oh yeah sleep apnea
will take you out so [ __ ] quickly the
first time late guys I'm Tanya and I'm
telling you for your own good the first
time your girlfriend your mother your
father your grandfather hey baby sister
you listen let her just lower last night
just not what you're doing stop it come
to the realization that it's gonna get
worse it might not be a year it might
not be two years but in three years
you're gonna start running into this
[ __ ] war unless you've had sleep
apnea it's tough to describe it I hate
doctors
what causes it do you know what causes
it fat guys but no but Rogen's got it
really yeah so that's interesting that's
right I remember him saying yeah he's he
a sleep at the mouthpiece but he's he's
got the the stature of like a water
buffalo right you know I mean like
there's a lot of guys like when I went
like that's funny when I when I first
got diagnosed with it the first time I
went for the doctor fruit you know who
was there Gary Gulman 2001 2001 was the
first time I even considered going on a
doctor and Goldman was there i'ma fall
asleep and I'm gonna this is [ __ ] up
with you to have and we started talking
about it and then I bumped into him at
the improv because hey I looked that
[ __ ] up that shit'll kill you at the
time I was killing
when it was killing 25,000 people year
25,000 many years something no no I'm
sorry the website at that time is
getting 25,000 its yeah like nobody
really knew about it Reggie died the
tackle from Philadelphia
he died from sleep apnea because you
wouldn't put the machine on it's that
big machine yeah and it's got the pipe
and it goes to the base and plugged into
the wall when you don't sleep
it affects [ __ ] everyone now I sit back
and I think about it I try to talk to
you younger guys I don't want you to
sound like oh he sounds like my dad let
me tell you something man I think of all
this I never slept bleep thinks like I
go find him like I was on a 2 hour a
night sky drop 2 hours a night 3 that's
you add it's sad
now when you're 20 you get away with oh
yeah because you have energy you're and
you get away with it musician in your
life when you're 30 you caught you catch
up to it so it affects your mindset it
affects your moods your hormone levels
Hortis all digestion we skin you start
gaining weight I wonder when Lee and I
started doing the podcast I think I was
holding on tight to 95 and we started
doing the podcast and I started going on
the road for 45 you know I and then
Thursday I get up at 4:00 to take a
flight Friday radio Oh which is so early
sad that I slept and then Sunday you
sleep three hours because I'm on the
first yeah I get the hell out of the
town I woulda member going to doc that
was 349 I came fifty [ __ ] pounds I
looked at my die yeah I see Rogan had
that dude on yes and I listened to it I
got the book I read the book I read like
a couple areas twice I agreed with him
in some areas like I'm good on seven
seven meet you I'm solid on seven
I'm seven I'm sorry yeah if I'm under
six I'm a demon like you oh god if I get
little six hours older woman I'm good on
seven I focus on seven okay you know
what
there's some nights I go to bed 11:00
and then five o'clock my dick is hard
and [ __ ] I gotta get up and get coffee
yeah and sometimes I get so high I run
my errands you know I put up the podcast
I pick music I send a couple of emails
yeah I checked this guy I [ __ ] send
the email to this chick and also done
ain't dirty once mercy leaves with my
wife when my wife gets back we breakfast
not tell my wife there's none on the
agenda at 11:00
and I'll wake up with eleven and then
get up and you know like now I know I
understand the importance it's so vital
sleep everyone you know what's the whole
saying about like sleep and success like
you know someone has told me before like
I think it's one of my agents like well
maybe you know you need to sleep less
and get more work done I was like that
is the dumbest thing anyone has ever
said to anyone no one who's successful
has gotten there because of less sleep
you know what I mean like that whole
idea is archaic now like the only way to
really become successful and health and
life and all of that is to take care of
yourself first and sleep is I've come to
really appreciate it every [ __ ]
morning I get up I don't pray for them
you know to go to town restore all of it
but I'm very grateful that I'm not a
hospital yeah friend of mine just
diagnosed with stage one Oh whatever
can't say quarterly that's good
somebody's early bah bah bah you know so
I think of how fortunate but you said he
goes what have you been doing I do
everything I could do like I drink water
at night I try to take those garlic
pills from
are to clean up the arteries I don't go
to acupuncture I go to cryotherapy not
the last three days because we've been
living in cryo [ __ ] therapy but I got
to know before you know I lift heavy
breathing a lot of weight
yeah you're doing a lot of stuff I do I
go to box I go to kick box if I catch a
kickboxing class because he alternates
on Tuesdays and Thursdays you do classes
when you're on the road too don't you
look up a little bit the [ __ ] prom on
the road is you have two things on the
road you have a thing called time zone
yeah which can always I'm fine
especially when you're going from here
look you saw really [ __ ] she Oaks I was
finding if I was at a place for three
days like if I got to a place on
Thursday Thursday night show
if there somebody had an 11 o'clock
kickboxing class that was over who you
know is friendly I would take the
[ __ ] kickboxing class yeah then
you've become friends of the people you
like I'm coming back Saturday Saturday
it just wouldn't work
no body your shot your shot your shot
you should like this weekend I'm going
find it to Boston and they want you to
do 5:00 a.m. press on Friday and then
shows and then you know it's just it's a
lot and then you're back on a plane and
then you're back in the timezone you
were it's it's so much for your body
even as somebody who was like young and
you know healthy it takes a toll on you
I think around feel like God bless his
soul and I think of ever since he passed
how it influenced me a lot
yeah if I wanted to keep doing what I
was doing at this pace how I could do it
and I had to stick to it but if you know
I had to sit my agent down explain to
him I'm not 48 I'm not 46 I could sit
there and tell you I feel I'm up I feel
50 seal the change in the last two years
like you feel more vivacious like good
orange I feel great right but I need my
rest
right you see what you need my pacing
now I'm gonna pace you know what
listen yep I love going to [ __ ] Tommy
still last night I have a great time I
giggled I giggled was in the back with
the chick
how late were you out I got 11:15 that's
not bad
I got a quick you know me yep I got out
of there quick bloomin righteous they're
a big shout out your birth father Louis
yeah mr. Hill a big shout out you know
it said I was talking to Joe I was
talking Jesu Mick it's so easy it's like
2:00 a.m. you know I won't even do - it
happened once a couple weeks ago I get
out of it but I cannot tell you that I
do not miss those days
yeah of it being accorded to like where
the [ __ ] we going
y'all walk over the paint or we get the
car and go to cactus yep cactus number 8
vine across the street from Freddie
Roach is Jim over there and yeah oh we
would go there and kill that when I've
rested I going to the store we would go
right down the corner the Santa Monica
Boulevard just right by Fairfax if you
move in there's a 7-eleven on the corner
two doors down on it's a Mexican place
that had the best chicken with rice and
beans smothered with red sauce yeah with
cheese and they burn the cheese oh nice
crusty Oh
tastes like cheese it's like that teen
with a [ __ ] diet coke stop it
you go home you get fired and those days
I used to sleep five hours I know and
that's this it's like nothing when I
first moved to Hollywood and you'd be
fine you'd wake up because breakdowns
you get break down to six mm-hmm so
whoever would be sending me the
breakdowns those days my goal was to get
up and get the breakdowns to the agent
by the time he got in the office I
wanted the agent to go jesus [ __ ]
christ
Joey Diaz is sending me another email I
would let him know who to call
what time yeah I call this guy this is
the role I'm looking to get you know so
no matter what time I set five hours
my sleep apnea got so bad for a while
how do you know if you have it your
sleep is there any telltale signs if you
don't have anybody sleeping with you is
it just when you die not you you never
really rested that's brutal
do not feel rested by two o'clock you
feel like this because you don't go into
that room yeah and even deeper you don't
go into that deep REM yep
so you feel kind of something isn't
right though this is how bad it got for
me I would take holy [ __ ] I'm completely
off Kelvin
for time off PM is six of them and I
would go to Bennett one and that one
forty five I'd be awake oh my god
because I know if I go to bed I just
wake up choking I got how many how many
years did you do that like how long was
that how you slept or didn't it went
from one level to win it like it went
from the snoring to me waking up my
girlfriend's the living room type [ __ ]
roommates telling me dog what the [ __ ]
it does sound like an animal was my
roommate in Hollywood he came out one
night he goes I had to put [ __ ]
phones on last night oh man put the
tower on my head he goes what's going on
with you so you're not even disrupt its
to sleep you're just replicating know
what it was I didn't really know what it
was but I moved in with a girl and she
was like amen what there's a creature
coming out of you there's a sleep apnea
demon coming out of you and then it went
right into this the snoring was going on
for a few years
yeah and I just rolled off the floor but
then I went through the six or seven
month process just made
things what happened that were weird
like during your when you were awake no
I will sleep and go to bed in the next
you know I'm up wake up my joking right
you know choking and then I would fall I
would try the couch and then I figured
out the only way I could sleep was on a
certain slant I had a sleep on a certain
angle like but pillows a certain way and
then I figured out that I sleep all
these movie stars they buy the homes and
11 million dollar homes and after 10
minutes in the shower they gotta run out
cuz there's no out water even though
they say here we go somebody nice as a
house and they got a beautiful house and
you and they shower by yourself for 10
minutes the house gets cold and you're
like why I have a million dollar house
luxury I lived in a building in
Hollywood that they had a connection to
the hot water Factory which meant that
the hot water never ran out right so he
got to the point where I was taking a
pillow put in the garbage bag over no I
would go in the bathroom lock the
[ __ ] door put the bathroom I'm nice
and hot and I would lay there and just
let the hot water Lam and I would wake
up I get five or six hours sleep I sleep
in the tub and a tub of water no with
the shower hitting in mind ok I thought
you were like constant like Whitney
Houston went to sleep that's how she
died yeah people realize people always
goofed around or she died of coke yes
but an awkward mattad she died of coke
because she was so coked up and I listen
did I mean we're here we're all family
here
one of my biggest things when you're
when you do coke after a certain level
you start getting paranoid yeah I've
never done it ever so one of the biggest
things were after a while when you're
alone after you make after you called
yesterday and she ain't coming over and
you call every check you know it's not
coming up and you start to like spiral
your mind by when you start looking out
windows and you start looking under beds
and you're going to a kitchen and see a
shadow and also at some point the only
safe place you feel with this addiction
it happened like the last five of the
ten years of my addiction my favorite
place was at the shower
Wow it would up with a certain position
I would lock the door close it and I
wouldn't have to Kurt in a certain way
you felt comminuted going in I can jerk
off and yeah hang out with hot water and
jerk off and a half I don't know how
many times I wanted to shout hang out
with hot water and jerking off sounds
great I would stay in the shower
until the hot water ran out like I would
go to Vegas somebody I don't care who I
[ __ ] it Abdullah Mohammed if Isis was
doing a show and they wanted me to open
for them in Vegas I would go just for
the shower because I know they're not
gonna run on hot shower get cocaine yeah
I could jerk off in there from [ __ ]
eight like I would leave there's no
restriction oh yeah I would go on a
shower for an hour come out dry up leave
the water on and do two more lines oh my
why I didn't go back in the [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] oh yeah you're indestructible you
must be Bionic all I've been through
but that's hot and then the sleep apnea
got to a level I would get in the car
with you what's up dawg nothing you'd be
driving at the first light I'd fall on
top of you and you go Joey you'd pass
out you'd fall asleep because this was
the position of choice Oh
for sleep right there that position
right there so when you fly do people
like shaky awake look we're getting
there oh my lord and I sat down I was
like number two on the plane I scanned
myself on there I had like a neck brace
handicapped army vet whatever the [ __ ] I
went up there I got on the plane dog and
I [ __ ] sit down United flight and I
actually took my head back and I fell
asleep
I don't know how long I was asleep when
I woke up to a circle of people around
me oh [ __ ] and the stewardess waking me
out calling sir sir
and awesome like this guy came and he
was are you okay we've never heard
anything like all the planes we've flown
it smells like a jet engine putting
their luggage in their thing we had a
physician to come and check you out but
you're gonna miss this flight I'm like
what are you talking about I know you're
gonna miss this flight we're sorry but
we can't let you get out and playing
like that I was sober as a judge
you know I don't drink enough I didn't
know how the plane had even taken off no
I didn't know what they were talking
about supposedly I was snoring so
[ __ ] loud on that plane that's people
couldn't even more like it was the
disruptive [ __ ] the pilot couldn't
even hear himself [ __ ] them they came
with security oh my medic they kicked
you off yeah they didn't kick me off
there was nice as they could be you not
on them what Helen it was it wasn't it
wasn't no nobody high-priced do they let
you fire they made you get off they made
me get off that a doctor check my blood
pressure and all this stuff and they
said okay you could get on the next
flight so I had to wait like five hours
Oh [ __ ] me about you or something but
that made me think like that was like
wow that's something's going on yeah
okay and I continue to avoid it it's the
only way to deal with it that machine
other other treatment this surgery servo
Tong and now with technology technology
is so great with it now and what people
have have acknowledged it like guys have
to just go get a sleep study insurance
covers it they did trust me your
insurance covers it and I know all the
scams for you to pressure your insurance
company yeah you have to explain to them
that you get in sleep apnea but see you
know today's world we live and I just
it's [ __ ] amazing how bad the medical
I have great insurance oh it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter echocardiogram
two weeks ago I just got the results
yesterday you know and I had to make 18
calls
oh my the doctor calls you you can't
call them back the [ __ ] paperwork
because it's horrible the loopholes the
locals
and that's a deadly disease yeah like
you could [ __ ] like I was at the
point where I was about to [ __ ] die
so what you have to do is get the sleep
study they call you the next day you got
it this is the extremity all right give
me the Machine insurance will tell you
okay it takes 30 days for approval no it
does it because I Drive I Drive my kid's
gonna have to drive my wife okay so if I
fall asleep behind the wheel and you
have to tell them that and that's when
they'll make an appointment for you to
go get your sleeps machine quickly if
not they'll store you with that for
another 30 [ __ ] days and then you
have to pick the model and wait another
30 days such [ __ ] no [ __ ] so I
go to Joe Chadwick the ex manager from
The Improv Miami yeah and the bar
tonight stolen so much money from the
Miami improv like they decided to lead
the Miami improv and open up the Little
Rock Arkansas funny bone okay
it was a [ __ ] it was the size it was
bigger in the commies thought it was an
old dance club yeah so they bought it
and at that time I had the longest shot
I know no no no no I did not have
anything they just liked me and they
said did you headline the room Arkansas
the Bible Belt I just don't do - yeah
but Ralphie had banana the week before
two weeks before that or Ralphie open
the room and Ralphie said it was a good
room at the time Ralphie wasn't even on
Last Comic Standing or anything but what
I do remember is that they put us up in
cheap hotels oh I can't stand it they
put Ralphie up in a fucked-up hotel he
broke the best numbers right so the guys
own the bed the hotel is a Korean guy he
was bad so this day Rafi comes back from
the grave little tighter that's all a
lie
listen he broke the bed and they brought
another benefit and he broke that one
that big son of a [ __ ] then they have
here's a better hotel but that's what
worked out by the time I got there we
were at the better hotel and you know I
don't know what night it was you know
you know like when the club cause you
says we'll pick you up at 7:15 being the
hotel lobby yep go into the hotel lobby
and I looked outside I didn't see
anybody so I sat on the [ __ ] couch I
was just minding my business and next
thing you know jessimae I'm getting
woken up again oh it's a white dude like
just the most handsome 50 year old dude
you ever seen your life just stone-cold
gorgeous yeah he's a gay hey sir
he was I don't mean to wake up do you
have three minutes of your time I'm like
yeah you know my god what the [ __ ] I
thought I was wanted by the cops I
didn't know what he was anyone in his
pocket and he gave me a card and he goes
I'm dr. such-and-such you don't know me
because you don't know me I don't know
you are but I will tell you I've been
sitting there for the last five minutes
listening to you and he goes now that
I'm up front and I'm looking at you you
have about two weeks left what just like
that it's also really good business I
was a [ __ ] around I'm sure it was
great no no I couldn't go to him he was
a Little Rock Arkansas I live in LA how
could he tell just sat down and said I
just listened to you for the last five
minutes you almost just died four times
because you choked right and then you
passed the [ __ ] out so the time that you
stopped your heart work yep so like you
go so you get what's called they call
the interruptions mm-hm
so he goes I didn't even count like he's
talking this lingo to me and at first I
was a little offended but by that time I
was old enough that I could take
criticism yeah like if I was twenty
twelve told to get the [ __ ] outta and my
this business
but by that time somebody had already
told me they sucked and Tommy that I
could have been good if you do that so I
accepted people talking to me in that
tone
he wasn't even talking down to me he was
talking to me in a way that was very
serious and he goes do you know what
sleep apnea is like oh not when he goes
you have it
and he goes at that time me joy he spit
a number out at me like what kind of a
number like how many people would dive
right let's the testers know and they
don't even know that died right and
they're just Pat they're just dying in
their sleep cuz this leads to obesity it
leads to diabetes so this is killing
people like a snake like an octopus it's
got eight ways to kill you he goes I'm
right now you die and three of them [ __ ]
and I was like that's that's intense
just be dying from something that goes
on in your sleep so he goes I want you
to do me a favor you don't know me he
goes this is my card and he put his hand
out because my name is whenever he goes
it's out of my hands or by your skin
color
you asked Josh wolf Josh wolf told me he
goes oh yeah there was a time there
every time I'd see I glad so last I want
to see and he goes you could tell by but
this is an addiction yeah this was not
sleeping
it's a accumulation of [ __ ] I was at
this time I was probably 360 [ __ ] you
know 65 not sleeping [ __ ] doing drugs
one drop on the road the road I mean
that's I'm senior Manik at that time I
didn't know how to do the road I had God
they don't learn the tricks I didn't
know I had gone on the road was Rogen
but I had not figured out why Rogen did
what he did
yep Rogen did what he did for a reason
and I wasn't doing it like roads right I
was doing it completely opposite the
road and I was losing yeah I was losing
I was just a [ __ ] so that's what made
me start tightening
my Road game I came back I told my wife
what happened and you don't want you to
tell your girlfriend oh [ __ ] we're we're
like okay shit's changing you got on the
phone yep
we change it he took the day off from
work and took me down there and you know
I still remember getting the machine the
guy coming in and waking me up like I
fell asleep in New York any time I would
get in this position this two minutes
I'd be talking to you yes you wish I
could sleep like that it was maybe I
need to put on some weight
it was really horrible and I advise
being like the you know you don't know
all these diseases no you don't
especially when they're almost like a
silent killer
I don't mean I know your dad just passed
on I'm very sorry about his tattoo I'm
because I have a best friend that he
said he'd look at his dad that was 92
yeah my dough is a be about 82 away he
is what oh I can be brutal he said it
was he does only died he was not that we
didn't love him felt relief he broke his
nose he punched a nurse he choked the
wife
oh man 450 is he woke up one night I
started choking my friend's mom who the
[ __ ] are you in this bed [ __ ] like my
dad was throwing his [ __ ] at his
roommate yeah yeah they just it changes
everything they'd almost start to
recognize you and like he didn't he
didn't he knew Jimmy like I asked Jimmy
about six months ago and I was home I
know you miss your dad they were talking
he knows Matt the end there's nothing to
miss it bet that's the most was every
rural part he was very shocked and hey
yeah you mourn them while they're alive
because you a piece of them dies those
have you [ __ ] hey how was it doing
yeah it's so brutal it's such a it's an
excruciating disease to deal with if
you're the caregiver like if Jimmy was
taking care of his dad that's it's so
hard it's so expensive to take care of
your family if they're at home and
they're sick and they're going crazy
every single day something else
something new happens we were like well
I don't know what this is and it's so
hard to not take it personally when
you're loved when a parent
or your mother or father is not sure who
you are and they're talking [ __ ] to you
because they don't know who you are how
do you not take that personally it's
your [ __ ] parent it's really it's a
brutal disease but it's also funny
there's a lot of funny [ __ ] that happens
that you know you can't plan for like
I've been working on it putting it into
my set a little but the day my boyfriend
met my dad my dad answered the door with
just a t-shirt on and his dick hanging
just below the Taoiseach my dad didn't
think anything was wrong with it he's a
cake come on in and I just kind of look
at Derek and he's like what why - I'm
like I don't know take your dick out - I
don't know if this is like a Sicilian
standoff and he just wants to see if
you're gonna take care of me I have no
idea so my dad was just there I had to
like scoop them into the bathroom and
get them taken care of it is this type
of disease where you really have to have
a humility about yourself in this
situation in order to handle it what do
they say what marijuana with dementia
well you know we avoid it by smoking in
can we I mean you know how I feel I'm in
the same family with you when it comes
to any sort of drug like that and he's
sort of like you know psychedelic or THC
CBD I saw a physical change in my father
Charlotte's Web you know Charlotte's Web
company Stanley Brothers they reached
out to me because they saw stories that
I was posting about him and they sent me
a care package a really really nice care
package and one of the things they sent
me was this olive oil
extra-strength CBD tincture and sorry it
was just all not a tincture it was a
droplets you know you put him under your
tub tongue it's like a sublingual thing
so my father was in the hospital my
sister and I were there and he's just
you know when people get older they're
just rigid and they just look
uncomfortable and his face was like he
had this like expression of discomfort
and so I looked at my sister I was like
what the [ __ ] do we have to lose this
isn't gonna he's not gonna go and wild
on CBD let's just see what it does so I
put a like four or five drops under his
tongue literally 15 minutes later my
sister and I were just standing seeing
if we could see any visible a
we could see him decompress we literally
saw him relax his shoulders his face
went from a grimace to just relaxed
he took a breath and he started
breathing normally and he just like it
looked like he had rested for the first
time in weeks and that's when I was like
well there's something to this that's
not that's scientific proof enough for
me and that's all we want from people in
our lives we just people we love we want
them to have comfort we want them going
out choking [ __ ] and throwing
[ __ ] you know it's brutal like a prison
scene in in in some crazy jail cell I
don't want to put my family through that
no no one does you know no one does we
were lucky though he was he was sick for
a year from diagnosis to death so we got
off pretty easy a lot of people sit with
that disease for five six ten years yeah
the average is like eight years that
people are sick with the disease [ __ ]
that so do you saw the degeneration
that's the sad thing Oh watching it it's
inevitable it's a [ __ ] train so Jimmy
has two other brothers one you know they
both had families look the way he goes
he got to the point where every time
they came in he's like I'm calling the
police
there's a burglar in that there's a
burglar about your [ __ ] sons we're
gonna [ __ ] burglars you know [ __ ]
like that yeah it's wild why like I
can't even imagine you know I've done
more acid growing up I know somewhere
along the line I have to pay for this I
don't think that's necessarily true
I mean you lived a life you know there's
people out there doing much work you pay
for look at look at Ozzy Osbourne now
yeah his Parkinson's that's brutal
no Mitch he sure had it those diseases
are so brutal Richard Pryor yeah Robin
Williams thought he had it but I think
it was blue body dementia we did that
eighties cocaine okay and I'm just
trying to be real with me train you
right now I'm bad because I did that
eighties cocaine yeah
knows what that does the essential
nervous right and then we have to count
in trauma right look at County TBI my
mom died oh that type of trauma yeah not
getting that role yeah CBS pilot you
know what you don't break us traumatize
you know our break of lives you know all
this is all tied into that
so as time as you sit there you know
it's like what they said what's that I
disease you get glaucoma
they make you smoke pot got coma yeah
you and I are preventing Varco you know
I just want to know that because of the
marijuana use yeah it's not gonna make
it worse listen if that's what you're
worried about
I mean I'm not a I'm a doctor on Mondays
on my Instagram but I'm not a real
doctor but I there's no science to say
it gets it where it makes anything worse
with that if anything it's a if it helps
I've said it once I've said I wasn't
times that there's a horrible lives that
lives in my head of me one day putting
peanut butter in my ass
and walking into a business because I
did because I want to sandwich know for
some reason reign of brain develops to I
have to get what age 25 yeah it's about
25 I did so much LSD from 15 to 17 and
then we went from some 1517 to 2007 it
was the straight central nervous yeah I
just constantly shocking your system and
I always tell people that at the end I
would towards the end like the last six
months of my coke addiction I was
getting [ __ ] a jolt in my spine like
a neurological reaction something that
was not good right it was not good yeah
it was not good then when I felt that I
would finish the coke I had now be it
for the night yeah wouldn't try to get
any more or nothing I felt that maybe
four or five times
and that was that I got off the [ __ ]
blow yeah so I know that I'm expecting
some are you is it a fear of yours or
you are you afraid of some sort of
impact like some sort of karmic
situation not karmic it's more of coming
to it you know you get a [ __ ] 1970
Cadillac one of the toughest cars ever
made whatever Mustang all those American
built cars especially when they were
built back then they just take so much
mm-hmm
it depends how you treated them along
the way absolutely there's something to
that for sure to think about how you
treat them a long way you know let me
figure it out on paper here let's be
honest the mileage let's be honest on
that found the family matter
yeah you figure from the age of 17 30 35
and see a doctor well I think during
those ages you're hopefully you're not
seeing a doctor and I mean just for a
checkup
and I mean I had [ __ ] a chlamydia I
just see I mean that's a Tuesday they
just want away yeah right now I still
remember the chicks monkey and seeing
the chlamydia drip from smoothy MIDI a
drip there at Coachella this year like I
know that I've had all those things and
you know throughout the you know for
free there was a couple years when
you're broke comic and you have to
decide whether you're gonna pay rent or
go to the dentist
yeah and you know what yeah it took mama
Jack Daniels I got a [ __ ] a half a
gram of blow and I ripped out all these
teeth all they should is fall back here
all this is saying
it's all done with a wrench and new with
a wrench and a ballot no oh please no
please Joey you have no [ __ ] idea
when you're living with listen when
you're living with pain inside of you
look at my face and pick up my face I
wouldn't get imaginary bugs in my face
and I would squeeze my face until I'm a
mr. Rogow I'm gonna have scabs all over
the [ __ ] place it was like a
different form of self-mutilation yeah
from the addiction now I see it I see it
you know I would get a [ __ ] head then
a little pimple and I would squeeze it
to the [ __ ] root came oh my god
cocaine made you paranoid like that if I
that's why I've never touched it because
I know if I did I would explode slide
all the surgeries I did there was one
mole that wouldn't go we are you going
to yourself dr. Diaz hello I'm full this
one out so there's one two three four
molars I pulled that it was there from
myself and you wouldn't even know every
[Music]
squeeze juice people asked Joe Rogan way
to go bro watch such a deep knows how
hot I was I had this little steak just
my mouth what Stan like we just have
let's do a mother tooth like this is
just a [ __ ] this is just a design the
tooth is completely different this mole
is gonna fool once you take the shell
off
it's like a [ __ ] bomb like so I had
the bone and I swear to God I would feel
it it was like I was chewing tobacco
once I felt this swallow up I'm like all
right it's time somebody bothered me at
the store I would superhero and
sometimes the white head would come on
this side oh that's when I had double
and I was like this I know why head will
go this way and the [ __ ] is use for the
tooth it would go down
from sleep apnea poisoning people with
your abscess juice that's why yesterday
my wife is like would you give the baby
the the medication she say she has to
eat something personally give it you're
a [ __ ] milkshake and put it in that
cheese well no it doesn't count
what do you mean caught in your stomach
means no [ __ ] stomach different
that's why don't believe most things
yeah because I lived with a [ __ ]
abscess for six years
okay you know those likes shows on TLC
like my 600-pound life and I sex sent me
to the ER I lived with my abscess tooth
for years needs to be a series it's so
oddly satisfying oh and like hope it
looks like hooves come out of people's
necks that's really good listen I love
this is one big insurance commercial
she's like a sister to me I went to a
half didn't but you know we all got
together you know you know what's this
lump but she goes I don't know and she
put drawing salve on it with her with a
pimp with a with a band-aid not without
that man everybody made fun of me what's
up with the band-aid annexe damn imma
waking up must have been 18 and I took
the band-aid off and the lump had gotten
bigger
I never forget just going like this no
touching no and it was like a hole
opened up and it was like a fly flew out
a [ __ ] no stream of pus and a drip
down the mirror and forget I was in love
with pimple popping after that
I couldn't wait together got another one
like that that was wrong well it sounds
like I won in your in your mouth for a
few years no one in my mouth that was
that one said and then you ever get the
one the best of the ones you get under
your tongue I do either have some [ __ ]
I ever gotten one of those you eat so
much that sounds like herpes you get
them under your tongue oh yeah little
white head you pop it no I don't know
yeah I think you should start a clinic
for people mune system has overcome all
these different you're gonna be fine
after a while you have so many things
and often your immune system just gives
up I think you're gonna I think you're
gonna outlive us all I really do knock
on wood I help with the awards I think I
just don't want to look like a half a
[ __ ] old man with three years and
somebody's got to push me technical I
kind of thought after City don't take me
to the nobody I never want to be one of
those dudes that shows up dressed up in
a suit like I was somebody all of Fame
that's you're squeezing your abscesses
everybody in the audience you know when
you're weird 75 and you have a lot of
issues you know how you'll have so much
fun you're getting so much fun you have
no like I got [ __ ] my arm got cut
didn't go to the hospital the scar is
God this one here you could still see
the V do you see that V yeah that V what
is it from it's like a satanic that's
its symbol had a glove on and I was
robbing a bookie named I had to jump the
fence and I ran [ __ ] yeah there was a
six-foot fence and I'm watching his
behind a Pathmark in West New York New
Jersey and
rather I'm gonna have the dog on my tail
and look back because if you look back
he glows time and I jumped out grabbed
the fence and I grabbed the bob wire
with this guy's at 19 I was a [ __ ]
Savage I made it over the fence but when
I want to get on the other side my hand
got caught in the fence now I talk about
bleeding and everything all the time the
cops are about 80 yards from me and I'd
never forget looking at him and my arm
being caught in the barbed wire and me
trying to go I like yell and I don't
know how I did it through the God's
grace I pulled myself up I loosened it
and I was loosening it I could feel the
blood my god I loosened it I dropped the
dog was barking at the fence and I just
had it [ __ ] back home and I could
feel the moisture in the gloves and I
went home and I [ __ ] changed my
clothes I wiped my face I didn't pass
out by the grace of God like it took me
a couple minutes I went to the bar I
told her behold money that I was waiting
to make it I wasn't robbed a book I told
everybody stay here yeah be in two
houses your envelope you got an 8-ball
get the party started adding up their
break the news to everybody yeah and i
sat there at the bar all night with this
glove with another glove on it believing
just drinking of people like what's with
the glove them I don't worry about them
mind your business just drinking all
night
next one day I woke up and it was like a
[ __ ] mess it was like am it so I go
to my friend ballheads house oh good he
sounds like a medical professional
heroin addict and I thought it took the
glove off and then this glove was
tangled with this llll so like Coco we
don't know what to do so they cut around
the glove and they took me to the
hospital with the skin so since it was
after 12 hours they couldn't stitch it
so they loosened the slit the glove they
took it out of the skin put the flap
over and made me put you know gauze on
it and they said you were gonna move
you're gonna lose the movement in this
finger and possibly this finger because
you cut a tendon I mean it was bad guy
is it good now you're indestructible my
finger up yes yeah that sounds like a
great Easter Sunday
Oh Oh a marionette turn me into Elmo are
you okay are you alive Lea no no this is
and it's amazing I know the fact that
you're still alive right no wonder
you're happy all the time like [ __ ] it
no wonder he wakes up in like it's
another day [ __ ] you guys you're
gonna be fine I will say that like any
sort of neurological thing is not like
Alzheimer's is not a normal part of
getting older but I don't think you need
to worry about it I think you're gonna
be good
we are from 1973 great memory yes you
have great memory I'm thinking like if I
don't log into Weight Watchers right
after I eat I gotta sit there for an
hour at night collective forgetfulness
it's been bad lately but we're we're an
onion dated web so i stimulate i can't
forget about 2014 the whole year tell
you anything about 2016 all I could tell
you is from 19 from 2000 backwards I
could tell you very more vividly maybe
it's better for your your own good that
you don't remember every single thing
we're not meant to remember everything
to be fair from 2014 to 2018 we weren't
taking about to 2000 milligrams at least
twice a week and you were taking it more
often
how many are in you right now Li none
really
yeah and I'm good please this
half-retarded not this time he took a
love beatin people come on be like hey
I'll say hi nice to meet you I've been
on the podcast like three times you said
maybe I was
like that puke on self no yeah I could
see you doing that Lee that was the acid
bucket of acid mushrooms Oh what's
you're gonna pills we get all that you
can't do that DEA's cornucopia because
it's always gonna work let's see ID for
you know if I do the DEA's cornucopia I
would shoot to another galaxy I'd be in
Andromeda right now I'd be up there with
Neil deGrasse Tyson floating on some
[ __ ] Milky Way in another building I'm
high all the time you're sober right now
Lee that's [ __ ] your eyes haven't
been open yeah no I know it's just in my
fan I have no idea it's just there
do you have sleep apnea probably Lou you
need to take care of yourself I know a
cute face you better take care of that
try
no but I was thinking about it when you
guys for I do need to go to get a sleep
test would say some guys must number
taze them right out guys it's [ __ ]
easy a sleep test the sleep apnea test
are you staying in a facility it's in a
facility no facility yeah one day
boy are you up yet to cozy bed they feed
you do you want me pay one time yeah
right now I'm supposed to go every year
the problem with me is when I look when
I want remember when I went to sleep at
me I was at 390 yeah she set your
highest weight not for 18 but between
working out and the weight lost I lost
all that weight that was here I got like
when I felt this bone I made an
appointment for the doctor I got a thing
I haven't felt this thing in 20 [ __ ]
years
yeah so because I lost that weight here
and now I lift I'm still burned now wait
I kept falling asleep on couches now I'm
falling asleep on a plane a little bit
you know not waking up like right
grasping for air my
when you have the sleep apnea world has
come a long [ __ ] way about a year ago
I busted out my own sleep apnea machine
oh my god what I almost died it didn't
work no no it was just to let you know
where I was then and where I am now
because there's different gauges number
20 being the highest and I still needed
help at 20 and 20 is me shooting like
you ever open up a fire hydrant
no I've been near one but I've never
opened myself like in Brooklyn in the
summer there's some of them not sure
that the 20 is that twenty is basically
we're keeping you alive like it's just
like what if if you don't secure the
mass before you do it you can't do it
partly because it's like when it's like
when you shot when I shot spider-man 2
there's a scene at Tobey Maguire on a
train like this they had a fan the size
of this building in front of them that
they told you you couldn't get 200 feet
from it was like hurricane winds that's
that's what that 20 was like and I still
had that old machine in the closet and
one that I go let me just see where I
was then and it was horrifying like I
couldn't breathe
air was coming in at such a pace it was
too strong for you that's how fat and
big I was now I'm at six to twelve so
now they have technology has really come
a long way so they call flex machines
and a flex machine is a machine that
rates you what you're feeling so if you
need is six you're at six if for some
reason that night you ate meat you drink
alcohol and you dehydrated and you need
12 the machine will automatically adjust
so you get 12 pounds of whatever
pressure I don't want to start talking
about stuff I don't know about is it is
it a pipe like when you put it over here
is it just a mask or it's a mask you get
me I like the mask mouth combination
right because I'd gone through my mouth
and I push out through my nose and
there's an escape valve right like an
air but that's why I'm dying to [ __ ] my
wife with the sleep apnea mask because
she would get hit with the escape valve
air
oh yeah well [ __ ] that she's getting out
more than I [ __ ] yeah dream of bad drug
but all jokes aside so for some people
they just could go on Lowe's machine but
you did the fault Jim Norton refuses to
use it so he's gonna live with sleep
apnea rest of his life he likes yawn
yeah he likes he's gotten skinnier by
the years and he still has it and the
masked ball is him there's people that
the mast bothers you now with that but
that happens is it like when I go to the
doctor and they do the hard stuff I
always take my doctor listen I go how's
it looking and it'll go this scarring
from the sleep apnea I go what about the
cocaine he goes nothing scarring from
the apnea so 27 years of cocaine didn't
really do nothing but the sleep apnea
did more damage [ __ ]
then the cocaine what how does it scar
you yeah I don't want to talk out of
line if anybody else knows and they want
to share this on the church website like
anybody knows just specific it there's a
part of your heart that this taxes Wow
like it was getting to the point and I
just admitted it to my wife when I first
got the machine my body didn't know how
to adjust to it and I was waking up with
my left side from my neck all the way to
my waist sore like the heart was
adjusting to her heart was all this
oxygen like it took the first night I
got the machine I slept well but then
things started looking better for me 30
days it went I had my skin color like
everything was adjusting 60 days 90 days
you have more energy during the day yes
I have more energy during the
days you know I wasn't as inflamed
because not sleeping in flames you yeah
I already was starting to get the four
eighteen was 18 pounds once you start
seeing the lump on the back that fat
lump that's yeah they just put the noose
over your head just a couple days that's
a hard truth because if you're sleeping
when you choke that means that your body
goes into danger
so releases the cortisol and the corners
or stalls us stars conglomerate's that's
like a quarter little sack yes so that's
why when you see people with that stuff
they definitely have sleep apnea and
their days are numbered
people we got take care of yourself body
that means your body's releasing
cortisol but it can't process it's in
shock I think I'm not a doctor I'm just
telling you what I've learned over the
years from reading and from time to time
I go back to the webpage to see what new
technologies yeah and or whatever you
know they have [ __ ] small machines
now the travel with yet streamline I
love my machine I love it do you have a
travel one yeah wow I have a travel one
and a guy from my man I'm gonna give him
a shout out over there was [ __ ]
Cleveland and Larry's my man Nick Nick
and the free machine they did yeah my
wire broke we went on the radio and we
said we needed to wire and soon that was
I got a nice extra sleep baton machine I
don't like it it's brand new
but he gave it to me so now I got one
for the road and one for the that's
great I take it really like I said ever
since I watched that Rogan podcast I
really do yeah what was the guy's name
the guest I was a doctor next time I see
Rogan ask oh yeah I was book about sleep
why we sleep why was I think yes I have
that book it's a duck i forget the
doctor's name i think i gave it to
somebody i gave it to somebody and he
read and was blown away yeah because he
was sleeping in chunks
he said something wasn't going right in
his life you need at least three of
those cycles to him sleep awake
9 to 12 then he would wake up and go to
bed from 3 to 6
oh [ __ ] that 8 to 10 sounds like a
chimpanzees schedule that means yeah
it's a bit that's also beings asleep at
me you're waking up you don't know why
yeah I've been choking yet but I have
that you children I need a joke you're
you're two days away from choking we
have that means you're choking your body
is waking up for a reason and now it's
ticking starting to get scared because
after a while you I heard my hamster and
it was so weird that even after it
didn't hurt I was walking a certain way
oh I'm still walking a certain way
because my mind is protecting that like
oh it's psychologically so you think
that maybe he's her that's not hurting
any mom's little kicks I'm squatting is
your brain anticipating because it's not
brains anticipating when you have the
sleep apnea after a while what's [ __ ]
up about is dad why are you gonna go to
sleep it's like why you gotta come to my
house I'm gonna smack it would you come
from my house if I said yeah you're like
afraid of sleeping yes you know you're
gonna you might die well how would you
come to my house the face I would looks
like you do that love why would you keep
coming over that's what it get to the
point like you like what I'm we're gonna
go to sleep right it's almost like a
you'll fall asleep on a chair and it's
an hour and a half and often your body
starts accepting that it's [ __ ] that's
brodo it's a [ __ ] that's brutal it
was so crazy how we adapt and almost the
adapting is the thing that can be
detrimental and I'm very lucky because I
would take those six or seven or eight
down all PM's smoking cigarettes oh [ __ ]
cool three packs a day at night and then
I would nod with the cigarettes and you
could have blown yourself up I was like
a junkie that carpet looked like I had a
bar like ray Liotta's face
yeah there's all pockmarks cigarette had
a brand new carpet for that [ __ ]
apartment
how many people do you think have lived
a life like you what percentage
a lot if you think so a lot the people
who didn't listen man I grew up a lot of
my era so I didn't give a [ __ ] it's not
like I had a reason to live you know
when you're just out there in the world
alone you in the back of your mind or
like I'm alone I'm gonna take chances
other people wouldn't be able to take do
you find your fans who come up to you
after shows or message you who have
lived a similar life and you've sort of
helped them through stuff
everybody's lived like not everybody but
you should watch like I call it uncut
gems you watch my life for years that
was borrow from Peter to pay Paul
that's a heavy stress life was that
close to reality yeah that's that's a
[ __ ] way to live always remember I
sold the membership to the mob for 2000
there are they taking new and I made the
guy full of application movie for years
I would see him and he go they'd never
call me and I got the part any day
they're gonna call you you know to the
mob [ __ ] show it was just something
that it was if you're gonna be my at
that point in my life of is if you're
gonna be this stupid I'm gonna rob you
and that was just that was like a
general that was my was how you survived
that was how I survive if you gonna be
this stupid
I got a Rob here if you're gonna if I'm
gonna come over to your IFIF jessimae
brings me Lily to buy it how to cope
some lady you're gonna rob them and lean
and I know Lee's you know his schedule
he leads to coked out or this is where
he stashes it this is going down yeah
you're that stupid I'm gonna [ __ ] Rob
and do you think that all goes back to
like being growing up without a mom like
not having that it all goes eternal love
it all
goes back to when you were raised
Catholic and you really really really
believe in God which I still do we
wouldn't I wouldn't be here if we don't
even if there wasn't higher power and
you live in the world you have is your
mother and then the lights go out when
you're sixteen you there was no therapy
in those days right it was shameful to
take care of yourself so no no wasn't a
how to take care of myself
I chose I could've lived in Florida with
family or in California with my uncle I
just chose for the first time I live I
hadn't accepted into this neighborhood I
worked hard to get accepted into this
[ __ ] neighborhood now I gotta pick up
and leave
[ __ ] it so I stayed in that town and
what happened to me mentally was I felt
that my belief in God what God takes
away a mother right what God takes away
a mother and what's funny was just my
wife I met I met this girl in the 8th
grade that was [ __ ] hot I like Irish
chicks
she had like strawberry blonde hair she
fair skin freckles yeah she was just
good-looking I always felt bad about
this I I dated her for a few months very
eighth grade jessimae innocent she went
the whole you know she went to we play
for st. Michael's CYO she went to Holy
Rosary Academy right there that was the
Sun I wasn't going to try anything for
90 days because it always happened with
sucking it at first yeah it's you know
it's like the admission admission to the
[ __ ] part Catholic yeah girls I like
the Irish girls and the Italian girls
right it was you know well faster be
Italian it was you know six or seven
dates and you a little bit Wow then you
tried for the [ __ ] for another month
and a half
one night they let you touch it just at
Patrick then they cry a little depending
whether you touch my [ __ ]
what's God gonna thank God or God want
you to be a horse knock it off huh God
wants you to be a [ __ ] yeah you said it
in the Box a great sound bite relieving
my Magma's that you do marry by duck and
then your finger them and that's another
three-month process three months to get
to fingering although you finger um and
then you know to leave it in there with
nobody looking and then you have to make
them come yeah the thing um once you
make them come with the finger though
they're in now you're there are you
there like hi can we get more of that
yeah now they'd like that now you can
work on this stuff and then it takes
another three months to taking back the
house and yeah it's just a process it
was just a [ __ ] oh these girls ever
straight took me like a cheese dog and a
high five no but it was awful me too
my mom had raised me a certain way
you're a good boy also me too I was born
as [ __ ] I'm gonna sit here and Tara was
a good boy me to story
I'm the Rogan podcast about me being 15
in love with Faye a MILF from the
neighbors she me too you know I'll be
sure to meet to her
I [ __ ] did angel dust and got some
flowers that my mother had in the house
or wait in the bushes right and I was
gonna attack on her with the flowers and
[ __ ] psycho [ __ ] I had never sucked
a [ __ ] before I'd suck titties before
but I wasn't a [ __ ] just rape or some
[ __ ] out of the blue you know like in
those days an ambush her puss because
she was hot she was like 37 and I knew
both her daughters but her husband was
like 60 and he knew you know he paid the
Philistine yes a girl after my own heart
right get the old [ __ ] she was bangin
I bet she was Faye was beautiful that's
a name of a pretty woman Faye one
syllable that's the woman who knows how
to put on eyeliner that was sticking up
yeah purgative pants issues to wear what
all the top oh yeah which way from the
74 make it yeah make it good look like
full milk jug and we would play
basketball yeah Juliet two dogs that
were blind to French people watch it a
heart so she would walk him across the
street then put him down yeah she's like
clucking broken things as soon as we'd
see her we let the ball go down the hill
so we'd have to go down and get it so we
could just look at say yeah you ever get
a sniff did you ever smell her no [ __ ]
failing favors like the [ __ ] prize
the neighbor ish it to a hot daughters
you know family yeah when your mother is
hotter than the daughters yeah you're
something in the water
I still see one of the daughters and
Facebook just gorgeous yeah she's
gorgeous so yeah I'd start talking I
said oh you couldn't talk to fake as the
husband was always in the balcony in the
daytime wait didn't it's [ __ ] work
although he's retired he was old he was
always covered the bills yeah she was
sucking his dick you know one of those
type relates right so we played
basketball at night and we'd noticed I
when she come down at night he was
already asleep at 10:00 so I was like oh
she make a little night walk kitty cat
go out in the alley well if you taking
my mind with Sully take the dogs out you
always could take the dog blind one him
yeah this so we'd be out there playing
bass one she'd come out with her
flip-flops well a little tight daisy
dukes this is way before Daisy was even
born she already was wearing daisy dukes
caught up to the cheeks yeah gonna lip
hanging out bad maybe i waving it you
know we just be sitting there like in
awe like she was like god who just so
finally oh my gosh i talking to her and
I was flirting with her fabula
thank you sweetheart you know the whole
oh my God look at me dirty because he
knew I was in love with fat and finally
one that was of my buddies we got down
we would drink in his [ __ ] we got some
angel dozens oh [ __ ] and we listened to
Led Zeppelin - it was four of us and we
each did me
Michael special maybe Dominus Michelle
we all did
a different instrument and we listen to
Led Zeppelin to cover the cover and then
there was going like a popular party and
they're like hey you coming to the party
I'm like I can't I got homework under
like home he's just an angel dust on my
don't worry about plants I was gonna
take faith down from behind the bush I'm
behind the bush get her Bush right on
Liberty Avenue she was across the street
go across the street into the park
there's no lights in the park and I
would just let run up on a tackler give
her the flowers she and Tom which I
loved and then hopefully we're gonna
make out like in the movies there's
gonna be like John Travolta Olivia
newton-john and grease right I really
could have worked out I really believe
this isn't it this this is why I do not
like the whole thing of you coming back
at me with something I did when I was 20
yeah no it's it doesn't hold up it's in
a different era
Don chomping know when you read the
radon chanting if anybody gets a chance
do me a favor and read this I'm trying
to get her publicist to send the flowers
and a gift certificate and a letter of
thank you to read an honest woman
radon Cheung look a braid down about
Weinstein know about [ __ ] Mick Jagger
whoa that when she was 15 she felt make
jagan it was not a me-too moment Wow we
knew exactly what getting ourselves into
so she goes there's nothing I'm trying
to attack my jag or nothing like that
she goes that there's a spectrum to the
situation I'm it put her in the video in
1984 the one song he different his solo
out on a movie they did a movie together
or something like that but she [ __ ]
came out the I dance and listen a
podcast The Hollywood Reporter podcast
she came out and [ __ ] said here's the
deal yeah that radon challenge oh when
she went that woman right there so she
said she knew what she was doing
oh yeah why did this article come out
did somebody she did a [ __ ] interview
you know no she didn't that this is what
a woman is about yeah I [ __ ] read
this thing okay
break that [ __ ] from Rolling Stone
frontman nights and when she was 15 and
he was 33 admission came to interview
accidentally blurted that she had sex
with rock when she was 15
Chyna later clarified the interview make
sure the relationship was consensual and
that Jagger did not know her age at the
time he never asked me how old I was I
never told him it never came up I
remember thinking he was cute he touched
tough of my hair and I thought man he's
[ __ ] beautiful he did nothing wrong
he didn't make me do anything I didn't
want to do Chung noted fully aware that
irrelevant wrote revelation may cause
controversy it was the seventies it was
a different era I wasn't the victim I
don't want to get into trouble about
this it wasn't traumatizing I knew what
I was doing wasn't schoolgirl why always
acting a lot older than I was
yeah I was grown up in 15 describing
herself as a Lolita Chung required with
sexual tries of the positive experience
he had great lips
according to chocolate two other
relationship on two different occasions
first after she had 10 to the Rolling
Stones recording sessions and later
after watching Fleetwood Mac with
[ __ ] jagaddal
it did not traumatize me it wasn't a
me-too moment it was something that
empowered me trying explained that I
knew the power to pick and choose
whenever I wanted and I had ever
experienced Mick was part of that this I
[ __ ] almost fell oh look I want to
cry because finally a woman says this
one went down yeah I thought about sin
how he got porch in a couple of weeks
ago as a rock or a guy that came on the
podcast and was referred to me and
people were mad that put him on the
podcast I did not know about the
allegations of him having sex with a 15
year old there was sixteen year old or
whatever I don't you know but I do know
one thing that one night I was watching
[ __ ] I let him eat like when I read
this psycho
Paris Hilton was on leather
when she was getting in trouble and [ __ ]
was she getting trouble four years ago
okay
115 years ago she was always in the news
for something right who's a party girl
and flashing a cookie doesn't let him in
a stir he goes I remember those yeah my
parents thought I wasn't bad might
sneaked out and gonna [ __ ] you know
party socialite now let me ask you a
question Cheston please tell me the
truth I'll tell you truly to feel I
won't lie in the journey was 16 if you
snuck out of the house was it to be with
a 16 year old kid when I read all this
[ __ ] I was like you know I know
iced remember years ago in 93 my buddy
gave me a job working a door and it was
well known that there was like these 20
girls that were like you know drinking
age was 21
yeah they're all young they wanted to be
older they knew what they would write
this is when I read that radon Jonathan
I was so happy that finally a woman said
what are you [ __ ] it's not all me two
morons in power yeah that's a [ __ ]
weird thing for a woman to say but look
what she said she goes I had control I
knew what I wanted I know what I didn't
want and reading that kind of made me
happy I don't know how we got in that
subject but when you when you lose your
mother and everything you want take a
[ __ ] on the wall yeah of course
so from 1980 to 1987 my life was to
revenge right were you we filled with
anger if I saw a pigeon in the middle of
the street I was your size I can't run
the ball that's it would you do
something like that
you're missing love I did things that I
never kicked the damn dog or an animal
nothing like that just a page
Yeah right to the sky that's what they
call him
this guy rats in New York City you just
feel this [ __ ] hate the society yeah I
wanted the world to feel what I felt of
course you know so I wouldn't try to go
out of my way to make your world shitty
yeah what's your mom's name Donora but
what I did was when I was in that
waiting cell after I got sentenced for
the kidnapping the first time you were
in the only time I was I mean when I got
sentenced that's why we're my piece of
myself before you were talking about the
cosmic revelation the Karma revelation
yeah I made piece of myself that night
that night about everything I didn't go
to jail for the kidnapping well I was
involved with two pieces of [ __ ] I'm
friends with one of them today dearly we
just spoke to neat they come to a show
like last year but we were three pieces
of [ __ ] if this was any other city but
it said go [ __ ] yourself
I'll bring your losses but caller I
don't thought they had a price charge
it's not on blame him I'm happy they did
I wouldn't be in today yeah I'm not
whining but that was the you know I mean
who would do something like that
somebody who was angry who didn't and at
that time I had no reason to be angry I
had a piece of ass I had a job at an
apartment I was living it was the early
those formative years stick with use to
the the anger I had was to like my I was
26 27 you know I was pissed at kids that
had parents that were taking you know
that was the first weapon I would use
will [ __ ] Emily you got [ __ ]
Barrett yeah you did that loss you know
so it was kind of uh I learned how to
reform love with all that it wasn't that
I was a bad person yeah I don't want to
say that at all just wanted to [ __ ]
take a [ __ ] on the [ __ ] world and I
think a lot of people can relate with
that a lot of people are looked at as
bad people but everyone has a source of
their trauma there's if there's a
certain you know group of people who
don't but there's some people who
just missed love and experienced loss
like you did as a child without having
that mother like you unless you really
walked it it's very hard to judge
somebody by something they did for me
it could be three years it could be 20
years I know the path two guys walking
up
I've seen people i'ma tell you one name
I'm gonna tell you one name that will
have met him he was a [ __ ] Punk
and today's sorry and look at me ah he's
one of my best friends but the respect I
have from as a man is unparalleled
I respect him more than 90% of the
people after his name is Sam triple I
love sin okay that's a guy right there
he's a salad dude I could tell you 20
thing Sam did 20 years ago that store
that I wanted to choke him then I wanted
to choke he's another one who's been
through some [ __ ] he's been through some
[ __ ] that nobody knows about but at the
same time I will tell you that I've seen
Sam grow up to become a [ __ ] man
yeah very a comedian love us a loving
friend
you know like I'm tight with Sam yeah
call them once a week I can with them
you know it's it's you see people and
you forgive all that [ __ ] yeah goes away
cuz I've seen him grow since then you're
allowed to make a [ __ ] mistake in my
world you know this [ __ ] that comes out
now what we years ago he choked me at a
party at least stick his finger in your
[ __ ] know if he made you sniff his
[ __ ] then become rude that's [ __ ]
rude at least you got a sensei you know
we could talk about this I I don't judge
anyone I love hearing people's story and
they're nothing shakes me off my axis
I've been humbled by life and I know
people come from something I'm intrigued
by people's stories and you know the
fact that you've come out on this other
side and you honestly look I don't know
what you think Lee if you're still with
us but I think I don't have a ventini am
look better
you can see them pictures yeah that's a
special from years ago now you should
put one on apnea machines on your
[ __ ] see if it doubles down it's it's
not it's armed look at that thing mm-hmm
it's how I'm reacting to things yeah you
get older and you get smarter a little
wiser you said something about pacing
you start to pace yourself you tried I
told [ __ ] crystally over last night
because crystally is two weeks from
having a baby you know and really yeah I
think is that public news
congratulations I explained to him that
yeah I go because he was telling me
about six months ago we had a
conversation in the kitchen at the store
and he goes [ __ ] Road you know
assists and he said a couple of things
to me and I gotta get it you know I've
been there I get it and then when I
found out the news I saw him about a
week ago and I asked him what I was
doing he told me I'm and it's due on my
birthday February 19th or the 20th or
something
that's a expensive birthday present so I
have the most expensive nor my birthday
so I was last night I pulled them aside
and I go you know you're going to see
when you have a child oh I don't know
what happened I don't know if it was age
mercy family how I looked at things
combination pick one thing but I start
to see where you look at your time being
valid oh yes I'm not good point I'll get
you from egotistical point of view I'm
just talking about what what's most
important to you being at the house to
you with your daughter or flying to the
Superbowl
you [ __ ] jerk-off friends where's
your energy being expelled where's your
energy being expelled
yep and that's why I say that's where I
think I'm doing really well that I like
having a good time I understand you're
getting married in Syracuse but I fly
for a living yeah you know I know you
from LA get married at the VFW I'll send
a package you know like you have to
learn your limitations
yes me now I have to go to New York next
month and shoot a film you know so I
know I got to get plenty of reps in like
my set on I'm doing two sets on the 20th
I know those are my last because I got
to focus on this film until the 18th or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you know you
just learn different things I used to I
look there's no listen there's nothing
better than being a comic and going home
at night and knowing do you have nowhere
to go anymore
yeah what the [ __ ] is your problem yeah
especially to discern a problem [ __ ] is
your problem
it's 11 o'clock I just popped 200
milligrams just to get started yeah just
to ease into the night just to ease I'm
just getting started
pop another one's about an hour I'm not
seeing [ __ ] the bed till 3:00 3:30
4:00 yeah I'll be talking to dead
relatives at 4:00 a.m. but yeah I
realize that yes [ __ ] horny as a
sound exam corny but it's so vital like
Joey really this what you tell me
yes look at yourself and go there's a
timing won't it better be there yeah and
consistency is key with sleep 12:30 yep
don't do around there I felt it for a
while there I would go home unwind and
watch sons of anarchy from eleven to
eleven forty nine and eleven forty-five
over off and go to bed
yep now son Diana can you know that
[ __ ] up my night I was also doing it
watch The Outsider I'm so taping it and
then we're starting to ride it and
and then riding until 12 and then watch
the sons of anarchy - what oh that would
make my mind to engage though I had to
pick one of the other so once I read
that book I'd pick the time no more
there's only one night I have gratis and
that's Friday night on the road that's
my get up on Saturday right all I gotta
do is make breakfast at the hotel yeah
you understand me so breakfast starts at
6:00 and it runs to ten if you're lucky
down at nine yeah I don't have to leave
[ __ ] if I have to leave the old time
he's gonna take a shower like not leave
it I'm in the whole town I'll have to do
is put some monkey recent my hair brush
my teeth take my blood pressure
medication go down to watch my [ __ ] go
down with the dirty monkey I do it I go
out with a dirty monkey I roll a joint
[ __ ] gentleman on Saturday morning I
already have a coffee in the room
prepared so when I get up I hit it I see
who called I check them with the wife
and the kid the coffee's made them so
half [ __ ] yeah you're still a little
waking up right you drink the coffee now
you brush your teeth you take your
medication you roll a joint I bring my
jacket down I bring my glasses down in
case there's a newspaper and I killed
two birds with one stone so I go down
you [ __ ] eat your breakfast and you
talk to the waitress a little while you
talk about how good the potatoes yeah
and then you get up you get another cup
of coffee
yes you do you go outside for a little
stroll so and you smoke that [ __ ]
monster at that and then you go back
into your room and you throw on [ __ ]
narcos yeah some [ __ ] on lifetime
for my 10:00 to 11:00 yeah 11 o'clock in
the morning you look at the clock and
you're like [ __ ]
I ain't waking up till lunchtime you
take that little three hours yester you
get up you wash your [ __ ] and you take
oil fancy oils no it's a quick wash in
the bush
they're just a river wash she's just not
a quick [ __ ] watch just a quick shot
yeah
I'll shave on that one no how old shave
on oh yeah just take this is a quick one
on the house to go to that local
restaurant that hell yeah the one you're
like oh this is the one lady told me
about when I checked in cheeseburger
yeah something that's known in the
community yes go check I learned it from
Chris friend Jolie gonna find the good
look gotta find a good local spot you go
to that local spot you're back in your
room by 3:00 they sure don't start til
7:00 got two options you've got an
option number one which is an app for an
hour and then your option number two
which is called a gym maybe do the
elliptical for money
throw some weights around fit I do that
and then go back upstairs roll another
off you go to the gym if you take option
number two you are in the option number
two yes you another joint to roll so
after you workout you drink the water
you go to lobby you get a little protein
shake and you go around the quality you
hit that [ __ ] number if you workout
at three and you get back by 10:00 to
4:00 right what did nice hour oh you get
an hour nap then and then you feel like
a new my god then you wake up and you
get another coffee yes and now you rock
it oh yeah if you're lucky you bang one
on it yeah quick little dizzy and [ __ ]
tricky boy hey dizzy oh yeah how much is
are you taking during the same three
coffees for eating a lot of [ __ ] I take
this [ __ ] when I come back from
breakfast how cuz I always eat a couple
whole meal when I'm on the road I'm the
buffet yeah you gotta get healthy so I
keep I get two eggs sunny-side up one
piece of wheat toast two pieces of bacon
light and the butter and I hit a couple
of pushes all out with those two coffees
by the time I get upstairs my [ __ ] is
ready to spit he's a [ __ ] government
witness he ain't stopping it's three
lumps to come up but it's really funny
cuz my ass always holds back in the shy
yes it only releases the stuff that it
needs to release it holds on to the
stinky stuff
is they had like a reserved [ __ ] 1001 is
so my [ __ ] so my [ __ ] I take a
[ __ ] Friday but it's a small one like a
little deer pellet you know right dick
and then as soon as I land at LAX your
body knows it's safe my body knows that
we're on the way home so now I grab an
uber and I give them a 20 right off the
bat I'll even wait for the app to come
up and then go get home because you're
gonna start smelling some we're gonna
hotbox it's [ __ ] free yes the 405 oh
I'll take the Prius and take a special
but I might get the [ __ ] Laurel King
and he's making the left I could feel
your [ __ ] like like that first brown
cloud come out yeah your turtle head in
and say a word I use in the front seat
talkin Arabic the one of his friend I
thought the window yeah they're calling
back home yeah so I just drop a couple
five they don't know they know take some
back to the cave so then they [ __ ] I
make him go past Lee's house on Laurel
Canyon and I make him make it right on
pop by his chicken there and by the time
I hit Popeyes Chicken I could feel the
tip of this [ __ ] yeah turning my [ __ ]
yep we get how he pops I tell him thank
you I pretty much open up the door roll
my luggage through a room take my
computer into the office and I go right
to the back office I got the bomb ready
I thought all I gotta do is fill up so
I'll sit there I hope it up my ass off
let the first grenade come on right nice
and it's like a 16 inches yep it comes
out smooth the other ones sideways it's
like the way Lee was born yes cricket
it's a little crooked
by that time they give me a little time
to wipe my ass fill up the bong get the
weed in the draw in the bathroom you do
a post [ __ ] bong rip listen to me I'll
pump the door so nobody cuz I have my
own bathroom in the back
on my back office and right there I take
those last two bonnets and that last one
will you coughs piece of [ __ ] flies out
of your ass one that was hidden I got a
legal immigrant I'm saying that
[ __ ] runs out like if you
smuggle an immigrant on the train and
let him out in California and just open
them and tell them calmly watch that
Mexican run dawg
it's like me familiar just start running
after that second bong it when I cough
and that piece of [ __ ] just flies out
and that water splashes 20 26 inches I
send the picture Tom Segura from him or
Tom Segura from him you sent him to
leave why do you wipe your ass in
between you got to keep it fresh it's
rude to your [ __ ] to me like that now if
you Chiefs get back together by mistake
now you have [ __ ] crossing yeah you
don't want anything in the way it is
real you don't want it you don't want to
religious genocide on your ass how the
[ __ ] did we get to this subject
what's wrong what is normal pee we were
talking about your mother passing who
gives a [ __ ] that was 40 years ago that
it's just [ __ ] dead bury the ants
even ate the [ __ ] dress by now learn
how to be on the road and being healthy
what's that look we were talking about
being on the road and being healthy yeah
why are you this weekend
Matt laughs Boston February 6th through
the 8th or 9th and then I meant
Asheville North Carolina at the funk at
aureum for Valentine's Day really yeah
just one night what one night two shows
yep we're doing a special special event
for all you lovers out there
you got a Valentine this year I do how
long you been with this guy a few years
three years yeah he was long-distance
long-distance for over two years that's
a good way to do it though you get to
sort of just pace it yeah it was good
for you take your time I mean you don't
you know get fingered as often as you
want to but at least you look forward to
it it's nice to have something looks
forward to and to miss
you living together kind of we're still
taking our time good yeah we're just
taking our time you know why rush into
it let's enjoy each other I don't want
to hate each other right away I don't
want us to be annoyed by each other too
soon so I'm like I'm a lot why don't we
just you know take this interval you're
busy
yes yeah I'm on the road every weekend
in February really yeah but that's good
though I mean I'm kind of complaining
but not you know you know how it is
you got the podcast yeah sharp-tongued
podcast I've got great videos yep and
Twitter you make me laugh sorry sweetie
I love with the sex stuff because you
would always show you foot yeah oh yeah
they're always very beautiful
I've nice feet they're all cut up right
now but they're nice you put you always
take care your toes and my butt I always
take care of my toes and I always post
pictures of my ass but it's a thirst
trap you miss him I don't want to see my
butthole it's just my butt cheeks
dancing the shower with that dog and
it's a thirst trap I put information
about Alzheimer's underneath it and it's
a hashtag ass for alts so you can just
click on it and then you can see all
those posts and find information and
places to follow to get some help
you're a good lady thank you the time to
come up and see him anytime it was great
seeing at the store yeah I posted the
picture up yeah Baskin who's that hot
blonde and the tucked in the corner I
was talking to the weed dude I was
talking to my guys you know getting the
stash I met I came home my head almost
exploded it really did that was like
last last night was a [ __ ] I did good
in the main room but I hate a bag of
dicks in the original like one of a
handful of comics were honest about
their wife said that people were there
they judged it they saw it you know yeah
so just a nice quality last night I came
home feeling okay last Tuesday I came
home feeling like I just left studio 53
I had a box adaboost
oh you know I was [ __ ] stoned yeah I
had a like 15 wins listen when you
either comest or when you know you're
hungry
Oh
you are any but they have the best date
fries in the front row I've never eaten
last night they were making Dungeness
crab what the [ __ ]
Pookie Oh was making Dungeness crab
people we Dungeness crab just a Comedy
Store
yeah the fancy [ __ ] but every night I
steal three of those steak fries I'm
gonna bum I rape they're eating crab go
home and I gotta [ __ ] put it on my
weight watch it thing you gotta make
sure you keep tabs last Tuesday I got so
high at that storm Tanya come I was
standing right next to you oh yeah I
went home I put 20 ones in the wings
after I couldn't even go for [ __ ]
pizza Joe's beef ah I couldn't do my
traditional last night I had the points
left but I didn't go to Joe's pizza cuz
my wife made meatloaf and it was [ __ ]
delicious
ah so I rather say they points for the
meatloaf yeah you got a pick and choose
where you put in those points I went
home and I had the meatloaf and it was a
lot better for me
how many how many points is 20 wings
that's gotta be a lot of points there's
a lot of but they're worn they want the
thing that save you weren't there
weren't the ones and Frank's butter and
right that's what saved right there was
a one Frank forget it that's the [ __ ]
you gotta add the calories
yeah the app just go ahead yeah shuts
down the app just shuts down for
witnesses give your life together 20
[ __ ] wings you fat [ __ ] I can't
imagine a hot wing but it's two point
it's five points the two-tier table
tools table tubes two tablespoons of
bleu cheese dressing
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I love blue cheese that's
why I get cheese dressing I make a salad
and just use two tablespoons but I mixed
that [ __ ]
yeah pepper and make this Reineke make
it spread out a little bit get all legs
on it yeah stretch it out chunks man so
much flavor I got a speech about I like
when you had extra chunks yeah it sticks
to the blue piece
I love wings either so good it's just a
[ __ ] deadly they are so deadly it's
dead junk food it's a pure junk food if
we had time I go right now he didn't get
wings Lily over there they got a picture
over there Lee was the winner of the
month for two months what did you how
many wings did you eat Lee no heat a lot
but no he's talking about
big wings I know they have small ones I
don't like that but I could actually eat
a lot of wings I love I love buffalo
wait like that's I there's a lot of
emotion with me with food I love
football like when I first moved to LA
every Sunday do pizza and wings I just
sit there somewhere you get the peace
yeah where you get I feel like it's hard
to find good pizza no no mama knows Lee
the wings the wings of Domino's tuck the
wings of Domino's are tiny there's some
local places that are okay here but none
of them are great Domino's not for wings
that's not pizza I mean don't you mean
Domino's to actually do I take that back
there's been a bunch of nights on the
road where I'm like let me what out of
the last [ __ ] 20 years I totally this
story I went back to hotel room one
night I could not take it like lawn or
that was coming on yeah
d'argo that a bunch of [ __ ] now I'm down
to a protein bar starving they get like
[ __ ] the Stouffer's meals yeah
[ __ ] they have in their marketplace
Melanie Pete singers uh whatever willing
to change
Domino's there's the Little Caesars now
is domina yeah we got thin crispy don't
you gotta go on the computer so I ain't
got time for computer I'll give you an
extra 20 get in a truck in 15 minutes
yeah 15 minutes a day don't don't don't
kid knocks on my door two gallons or so
light in the ass for two counts was part
of the deal I said just bring me
whatever you got he brought me the pizza
I've been in termite is the worst to
have already ate two slices because
there weren't even slices it was kinda
square yeah question so any like four
slices don't you know I went and I
walked all the way in the hole and I
stuffed it into the
it's so bad I swear them my daughter's
two hours later I was in that hallway
and that garbage taking the pizza [ __ ]
garbage that's how much of a disgusting
[ __ ] I am don't forget
Valentine's weekend I'm over at the
Tempe improv Thursday the 13th Friday
and Saturday the party starts Thursday
night we got me we got [ __ ]
everything stars they're making a
comeback John Lennon's gonna be there
Beatles are gonna be there Bruce for
everybody
Thursday night Thursday 8:00 o'clock
[ __ ] Tempe improv then the 28th the
February I'm at Treasure Island in Viva
Las Vegas you were gonna be in Boston at
Boston this weekend uh Asheville North
Carolina at the funk at aureum and then
dr. grins the last weekend of February
good for you that's a good [ __ ] car
it is fun it is a lot of fun people
hard-working people and they love comedy
I've got some beefs bumming all the way
the [ __ ] in Mishawaka you spun me would
you call me explain this all the way up
on top
it's where penguins go to migrate and
Mishawaka is a neighborhood where
notre-dame is yeah it's southern Indian
northern in the end I guess southern
Michigan I developed in Michigan they're
good people great comedy audiences great
yeah they really are
dr. grins I mean when there was two dr.
grins really it was two clubs in Grand
Rapids the Yoda brothers had two clubs
in Grand Rapids they had dr. grins and
they had another one but [ __ ] it that
was a long time saying [ __ ] it I want to
tell you guys a little story about
something real quick before you go
[ __ ] anywhere all right there was
this guy cafe out Taurus CEO Dylan
Moskowitz he experienced how challenging
hiring could be and after enough
successfully searching for director of
coffee for his organic coffee company
but then some mapping he switched the
Zipp recruiter and he saw an immediate
difference
and you could too by signing up for free
at zip recruited doc Travis and the
church is brought to you by sip
recruiter I love these guys why because
hiring is challenging but there's one
place you could go we're hiring is
simple fast and smart and that zip
recruiter plane and that's it they don't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them for you and it's what are you
bothering me for and it's technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job that's the difference so you
get qualified candidates faster in fact
after posting his job on zip recruiter
mr. Moskowitz said he was amazed by how
quickly the great candidates were
applying and found there's no director
of coffee in just a few days that's it
recruiter don't play games all right you
got a company you're looking to make
money you're not time to play games with
zipper crew in a zip zip zip you're done
with results like that it's no wonder
four out of five employees who posts on
zip recruiters get a quality candidate
within the first day joy what are you
talking about within the first day joy
but what do you know that within the
first day that's what you need that's
time and money
that's what uncle Joey's saving you
today so do me a favor go to zip
recruiter comm slash Church grab a pen
zip recruiter comm slash Church that zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church zipper
crooner is the smartest way to hire I
also want to talk to you about on it
my favorite why because listen they got
a product and if you don't like it
they'll give you your money back and you
don't have to [ __ ] send them the
product when somebody had when was the
last time you bought weed it wasn't good
they gave me the money back that don't
happen that's how much I'd it believes
in alpha brain copper brain works it's
keeping me together it makes me forget
what I had for lunch but I remember
other things like what Mindy heads [ __ ]
look like in 1984 I don't [ __ ] know
what you
I was a Mindi head she gave good head
they called the Mindy head what do I
know what happened to her [ __ ] like I
look for her on Facebook but I can find
her on the head so I moved on with my
life anyway
do me a favor go to Hana calm right now
take a look at what they got from the
CMT coconut coffee creamer to the jerky
to the organic mint chocolate protein
bars shrimp tech shrimp export now
because of the Chinese people shrimp
deca moon [ __ ] them I can't even go for
a [ __ ] spare rib now I see a [ __ ]
kung fu movie I gotta take two [ __ ]
shrimp Thai communes ain't that a [ __ ]
shroom and I got nothing as Chinese
people you know I love you yeah the
young tying me said corny I cheer the
dragon 1985 anyway going on it calm
right now press in church boom and get
10% off your first oil delivered right
the house it's that planning that simple
I want to thank my girl jessimae Peluso
one of my favorites
thank you getting prettier every time I
see most importantly I want to thank you
savages for supporting us and for
listening to the church don't forget you
bad [ __ ] I know my man Pat
she'll be there Thursday night at the
Tempe improv my girl from [ __ ] my
little Indian girlfriend is coming up
I forget what her name is nothing is a
[ __ ] bad-ass [ __ ] she's coming up so
the party's gonna be at the Tempe improv
One Show Thursday to Friday to Saturday
then Treasure Island on the 28th I think
it's a 28 just gonna treasure out it
coming for the weekend what's gonna cost
you to go to Vegas bring your girlfriend
let's have a good time my [ __ ] around
I want to thank my girl again I want to
thank the [ __ ] who's doing
phenomenal lately he's looking north
tip-top Magoo look they're so happy
thank you guys I love [ __ ] have
a great week and I'll see you guys
Monday morning
ready to rock the rest of you
[ __ ] I see you in Tempe next
week thank you for listening to have a
great great week god bless you guys